hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast to know mix in a clinic
medical ethics and policy presented by
dr. Amy McGuire we're excited to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots for more
information please visit lab roots com
my name is Tim cam I'm from leopards and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you can
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located at the lower left of the
presentation window and type in your
question in the box that appears on the
screen will answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that
will be you'll be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge this window click on the screen
icon located on the lower right hand
corner finally if you have trouble
viewing or hearing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of your presentation
window or just use the Q&A button at the
lower left and type in the question and
let us know that you're having a problem
now I'd like to introduce our speaker
dr. Amy McGuire dr. McGuire is the Leon
Jaworski professor of biomedical ethics
and director of the Center for medical
ethics and health policy at Baylor
College of Medicine she's naturally
recognized for her research and ethical
legal and social issues in biomedicine
with a particular focus on the research
ethics and the clinical integration of
emerging genomic technologies currently
she is studying issues related to
genomic data sharing the policy
implications of emerging business models
for next generation sequencing and
ethics and psycho psycho social impact
of whole genome and whole exome
sequencing her research is funded by the
NH and nih nhgri enzyme and the NICHD
she has served on the National Advisory
Council for Human Genome Research
Institute and is currently a member of
the Advisory Committee for the green
wall faculty Scholars Program and
bioethics dr. McGuire is the recipient
of two fulbright & Jaworski
LLP faculty excellent awards for
teaching and evaluation and educational
leadership please join me in welcoming
dr. McGuire I will now turn it over to
her for her presentation okay thank you
soon good afternoon everybody it's it's
great to be with you virtually for this
hour that we have and I'm going to talk
to you today about some of the medical
ethics and policy issues as we start to
integrate genomics into clinical care so
it's always helpful to remember that in
2007 it was the first time we had ever
done whole genome sequencing on an
individual human being and in the less
than 10 years since then it's estimated
that by the end of this year we'll have
done whole genome sequencing on about a
million individuals worldwide and as you
can see from this graph following any of
these various possible trajectories the
number of sequences that we will have
doing in the next ten years is going to
be exponential and so I think this
really indicates and shows that whole
genome sequencing and whole exome
sequencing are being rapidly integrated
and adapted into routine clinical care
as the director of the National
Institutes of Health in the United
States Francis Collins has predicted
over the course of the next few decades
the availability of cheap efficient DNA
sequencing technology will lead to a
medical landscape in which each baby's
genome is sequenced combined with the
use of met of mobile health technology
to assist in real-time monitoring of
such things as diet exercise blood
pressure heart rate and blood
chemistry's division of the quantified
self will become a reality for many of
us so this is sort of the prediction and
the vision of what the future of
genomics and precision medicine are
going to look like and in fact we're
currently already integrating genomics
into clinical care in a variety of
settings this is a paper actually from a
couple years ago out of the baylor
college of medicine
then whole genome sequencing lab where
we were reporting on the first two
thousand whole exome sequences that we
had done primarily on children with
undiagnosed genetic diseases and in that
population we were actually able to have
a diagnostic yield of 25% and these are
kids who had been on long diagnostic
Odysseys and had really had no
diagnostic information prior to whole
exome sequencing and more recently we
reported results from our cancer
genomics lab for the first hundred and
fifty pediatric cancer patients who had
gotten a tumor in germline sequencing
and in that population we found that
there were somatic mutations of
established clinical utility in three
percent of that cohort and somatic
mutations of potential clinical utility
and twenty-four percent looking at the
germline and these individuals we found
that diagnostic to remind findings
related to cancer and ten percent so I
think both of these papers and what
we're seeing coming out of other groups
as well shows that there is some
clinical utility and quite a bit of
clinical utility in doing whole genome
and whole exome sequencing particularly
for certain patient populations that
have particular phenotypes but what
about individuals who don't have any
known phenotype that we're trying to
diagnose so this is a study that we're
working on in collaboration with Robert
Greene from Brigham and Women's Hospital
and Harvard Medical School called the
med seek study and it's a randomized
trial of integrating whole genome
sequencing into clinical care and to
patient populations and primary care
patients as well as cardiology patients
who have been diagnosed with
cardiomyopathy and in this particular
study individuals are randomized to
either receive whole genome sequencing
or to receive standard of care which it
for us is just an enhanced medical
history family history and we're
returning to the participants in the
study information about Mendelian
disease risks that are secondary
findings carrier status and any cardiac
risk allele that we find and we're
recording findings from
an analysis of about fifty forty six
hundred genes and you as you can see
from from this chart in about twenty one
percent of the cases out of the hundred
who have been sequenced we found
Mendelian disease risk secondary
findings and in ninety two percent of
the cases we found carrier status
findings of those who are in the
cardiology cohort which were 50
individuals about half of them had a
diagnostic finding related to their
cardiomyopathy of those 20 of them are
forty percent had previously received a
positive genetic result from a
cardiomyopathy panel and ninety-five
percent of those results were confirmed
and then of those who had not received a
previous finding on the panel thirteen
percent of them had a positive result on
whole genome sequencing so again we're
finds finding quite a bit of clinical
utility of diagnostic yield using whole
genome and whole exome sequencing in the
clinical care of patients but not
everybody is interested in getting their
whole genome sequencing information back
or undergoing whole genome testing in
the clinic and so we have two studies
that are kind of looking at how
individuals use and and choose to use
whole genome and whole exome sequencing
so the first one I already described
which is the med seek study which was
the randomized trial of whole genome
sequencing and primary care and karlik
cardiology and then we have a similar
study also with Robert Greene and Alan
bags from Boston Children's Hospital and
ribbon women's hospital which is a
randomized trial examining the impact of
integrating whole genome sequencing into
the care of newborns and in both of
these studies we have found that a large
portion of individuals who are contacted
about study participation actually
actively decline participation in the
study so we have recently finished
enrollment into the med seek study and
based on the numbers that we had at the
time of this analysis you can see here
that thirty-four percent of individuals
actively declined participation and 51%
decided not to get sequence which means
that they either were unresponsive or
actively declined and in the baby seek
study we've even had a low
major decline rate of seventy four
percent of parents who are not
interested in having their baby sequence
which was kind of surprising to us
because we had done a hypothetical
survey of the same population of women
who had just given birth in the
hospitals that we are recruiting from
and ask them how interested they would
be to have their child genome sequence
and about eighty percent said they would
be very interested in participating in
the study to have their child's genome
sequence so I think that's a good lesson
in hell some people may say that they're
that they're interested in something or
have a preference for something but when
it comes to actual decision making they
may make a entirely different decision
so why were these individuals not
interested in getting their genome
sequenced there were many reasons that
they gave for for those who declined
participation of why they declined
participation the most common reason was
because of the study logistics these are
both very involved studies and they both
involved quite a bit of longitudinal
surveying and a large time commitment on
behalf of the patients or the parents of
the patients but they also gave ethical
legal or social reasons for why they
were not interested in participating in
these studies and the two primary Elzear
ethical legal social reasons that they
gave or that they were concerned about
their privacy and about potential
discrimination and they were concerned
about the potential psychological impact
of receiving unwanted results from whole
genome or whole exome sequencing so let
me talk about each of these a little bit
in turn with regard to privacy and
genetic discrimination this is something
that we've heard quite a lot over the
years that individuals generally and the
public at large has a lot of concerns
about potential genetic discrimination
and this is an interesting public
concern because we haven't seen too many
really documented cases of egregious
genetic discrimination but we have a lot
of anecdotal evidence that it happens
and it exists and so in the United
States we passed a law in 2008 a federal
law called genetic information
non-discrimination Act which protects
against genetic discrimination in the
context of health insurance and
employment it is not a comprehensive
protection so individual individuals can
still
discriminated against based on their
genetic information and life insurance
long-term care or disability and other
non non insurance and non employment
context and what's really interesting is
we recently did a survey using
Mechanical Turk mechanism on Amazon in
2014 and we surveyed almost 1,500
individuals in the United States and we
wanted to get a sense of how effective
has this law Gina been in a laying
individuals fears about genetic
discrimination and what we found is that
seventy-nine percent of our respondents
were unaware of the fact that Gina
existed or what the law was and this was
compared to only thirty percent who are
unaware of the Health Insurance
Portability and Accountability Act or
HIPAA twenty one percent who are unaware
of the American with Disabilities Act
and only three percent who are unaware
of the Affordable Care Act so we try to
ask them about similar federal
legislation that applied in the United
States just to get a source of
comparison we then gave them a
description of what hipa protects and
what I mean I'm sorry of what Gina
protects and what it doesn't protect and
what was very interesting as we said
okay now have knowing that this law
exists are you more or less concerned
about genetic discrimination and about
your privacy and twenty five percent of
our respondents were less concerned
about discrimination but thirty percent
were actually more concerned about
discrimination and I think it's because
they realized that this is potentially
something that they needed to be
concerned about that they haven't really
thought about and they also realized
that the law in the United States is not
a comprehensive law that protects them
against discrimination in all forum now
other countries do have more extensive
protections from a legal perspective for
genetic discrimination and one example
is the human tissue act of 2004 and this
is a law that actually criminalizes the
use of DNA for analysis without explicit
consent in most circumstances and so
this is a much stronger protection
against the use and analysis of genetic
information without consent so now
turning to the second conceal see
concern that we heard from
from our decliners the potential
psychological impact of genomic testing
and this is something that you also hear
a lot of of concern about with regard to
what are the risks of integrating whole
genome sequencing and whole exome
sequencing into clinical care so what
are the data tell us about how people do
respond to the genetic or genomic
information that they're getting well
some of the early studies looked at how
people responded to particular genetic
testing information so one of the most
well-known studies is a decades-old
study called the reveal study that
looked at individuals who are at risk
for Alzheimer's disease and they tested
them for the apoE gene variants and told
them whether they're they have a genetic
increase dramatically increased risk of
getting Alzheimer's disease and then
they look to see whether that created
anxiety or depression for those who had
positive results and as compared to
individuals who didn't get the genome
the genetic information and what they
basically found which you can see on the
graph here on the side of the of the
slide is that there was no significant
difference um sort of overtime in their
levels of anxiety now the other study
that's on the slide is a study that
looked at individuals who are getting
sort of genome-wide information using a
panel through the company now igenix
when they were offering
direct-to-consumer genomic profiling and
what they found also is that primary
analyses showed no significant
differences between baseline and
follow-up and anxiety symptoms for
individuals who had gotten genome-wide
testing done so we're also looking at
the impact of doing whole genome
sequencing from a psychological
perspective on individuals in the
primary care setting as well as in the
setting of cardiology or
cardiomyopathies in the mid seek study
so this is really the first study that's
kind of looking at this in a randomized
fashion for individuals who are both
ostensibly healthy as well as
individuals who have a particular
disease phenotype and what we have found
so far this is preliminary data is that
there really is no significant
difference between our control group and
the individuals who get whole genome
sequencing and their levels of anxiety
or depression over time from baseline to
six months post disclosure and something
important to point out here is that even
at baseline all of our anxiety and
depression scores fall within the normal
range which is 027 and this is on a
six-point scale so you can see that
they're all in the normal range and that
they don't significantly increase or
even really decrease based on
randomization arm but one of the
questions that has come up for us is
whether although it doesn't seem to be
that there are significant clinical
psychological impacts or sequela from
receiving whole genome or whole exome
sequencing are there more nuanced sort
of social phenomena that are taking
place and so one of the concerns is
particularly with newborns if you're
doing whole genome and whole exome
sequencing is how is going to how are
they how are individuals parents and
others going to respond to risk
information about their newborns and is
it going to impact the way that they
interact with those children as they go
through life is it going to impact the
way that they interact with each other
is it going to impact the way that they
the expectations that they have
internally for how their their children
perform and and and what they do in
their life and so in our baby seek study
where we're sequencing newborns those
are some of the outcomes that we are
studying and we don't have enough data
to present that here but just to give
you a sense of what we're looking at
we're looking at whether getting genomic
information particularly risk
information for newborns creates sort of
this sense of a vulnerable child where
parents are more likely to be worried
every time the child gets sick to take
them to the pediatrician more frequently
to have you know anxiety about the
health of their child we're also looking
at whether it has an impact on
parent-child bonding and attachment and
we're using
various validated measures for that and
then we're looking at the impact on the
partnership relationship the marital
relationship and whether it increases or
decreases marital conflict and so those
are some of the important outcomes that
we we're looking at with regard to how
this type of technology integrated into
newborn care might impact children and
we're hoping to do that more
longitudinally so we can see what those
impacts are so that's sort of the the
first set of issues that I wanted to
discuss around the clinical integration
of whole genome and whole exome
sequencing the second set of issues that
I really wanted to talk about is what I
think is really one of the biggest
bottlenecks to the effective and ethical
integration of genomics into clinical
care so we can sequence individuals and
we can get tons of information about
them but knowing what to do with that
information and knowing what it means
for that individual or that family is
where we can run into a lot of difficult
and challenging issues and where the
science kind of lags behind the
technology so I'm going to share a case
study that I think illustrates the need
for more robust databases and then talk
a little bit about some research that
we're doing looking at how we can
increase data sharing and develop the
types of databases that will help move
this forward so this is a story about an
individual who who I know and it's a
baby named Hannah who was born without
complication in July of 2015 so she's
almost a year old and at the time of her
birth she was a she was born in the
state that requires newborn screening as
a public health measure as most states
in the United States do and when she her
parents got back her newborn screening
results they found that she had a
positive result which which clinically
referred to as newborn screening
screening failed and they repeated it
multiple times and she continued to get
a positive result so she was thought to
have a particular deficiency that didn't
really
make sense from the perspective of how
she was presenting she seemed to be a
perfectly healthy child as she was
presenting to the physicians and to her
parents and so the recommendation from a
clinical perspective was to get a
genetic panel done to confirm the
finding on the newborn screen and the
panel did not confirm the finding so
they ruled that out so now they really
didn't know what was going on with
hannah and the recommendation was to do
whole exome sequencing and mitochondrial
sequencing to try to get some answers of
what might be going on from a clinical
perspective so they conducted the whole
exome sequencing and they found a
variant of uncertain significance
associated with propionic acidemia but
her enzyme levels seem to be okay and so
the physician said well if she has this
propionic acidemia then it's most likely
to be a very very mild case of it and
it's not something to worry about about
a week later they received her
mitochondrial sequencing results and it
revealed a de novo mutation in the ATP
six gene and she was a hundred percent
homo plastic for this so the geneticists
who were doing this analysis went to the
databases and said what what is this
mutation in the ATP 16 mean what does it
mean for hannah how can we interpret
this what can we tell her parents so
what they found in the published
literature were that there were four
published cases of this particular
mutation and all of the published cases
had been found in kids who had been
symptomatic with a disease called muse
disease now these disease which I wasn't
familiar with before I heard this case
apparently is a really devastating
disease that occurs in childhood and the
way it's been described to me from my
clinic by my clinical colleagues is that
it's essentially like ALS and kids where
children will develop symptoms of the
disease and they will then become
progressively paralyzed and ultimately
die within a couple years so it's a
terrible terrible disease and not
something that you want to hear that
you're beautiful presumably perfectly
healthy newborn child might get or might
have
the problem is is that in the databases
there were no known cases of an
asymptomatic child with this particular
mate mutation so what do we make of this
we have four cases of individuals who
are symptomatic with these disease where
this mutation was found no asymptomatic
children where we have found this
particular mutation but is that because
they weren't tested mitochondrial
sequencing isn't done routinely on all
healthy children usually it's only done
on children who have problems and the
major problem is that our databases are
therefore incomplete and so we don't
know if this particular mutation only
exists in children's with these disease
we don't know how penetrant it is if
it's a hundred percent penetrant or it's
much less so and we don't know what this
means for hannah so in talking to
Hannah's mother as she said you know
looking back when she was waiting for
the whole exome sequencing results to
come back she said all I wanted then was
for genetic sequencing results she said
been in retrospect those really cause
much more emotional pain and uncertainty
for her family than they did help
because now they have this sort of
situation where they have a beautiful
currently healthy child who they really
have a tremendous amount of uncertainty
about whether she might get this
devastating disease and what sort of
that genetic mutation means for her and
yet there's nothing they can do about it
in the short term so I think that that
this case really illustrates why we need
to build up our databases so that we
have a better understanding when we
identify a particular mutation what it
might mean for the individual patient in
front of us and so this there's been a
lot of work being done over the last
several years to talk about how can we
share data across institutions how can
we share data internationally how can we
share data from clinical labs and
research labs and really be able to
build robust databases that can help us
with the interpretation piece of the
pipeline of clinical genomics and so i
just showed here one of the reports that
came out to
thousand eleven by the National
Academies of Sciences where they really
sort of set forth this vision of meaning
to build what they call a medical
information Commons and this is an idea
of a data repository that links layers
of molecular data medical histories
including information on social and
physical environments and health
outcomes to individual patients and the
vision was that data would be
continuously contributed by the research
community from the medical records to
participating patients and at the time I
think the thought was that this would be
somewhat like Google Maps and it would
be one sort of centralized database and
I think now we're seeing more and more
models that are being developed that are
more locally controlled and federated
but this idea of having a very very
robust deeply phenotyped linked
information including genomic
information as one that is truly the
vision for how we're going to get to
where we want to get to with genomic
medicine so one way that we're trying to
do this in the United States recently is
through the President Obama's precision
medicine initiative which was announced
about a year and a half ago and the
precision medicine initiative is in an
effort to disrupt the old paradigm of
carrying out scores of studies designed
healed narrow results by creating this
massive research cohort that would
collect health information from at least
a million volunteers from sources as
disparate as medical records to make
genetic analysis smartphones or wearable
sensors so it's a very broad vision we
now have sort of the cancer Koch work
that's being built by the National
Cancer Institute in service to the
cancer moonshot project that Vice
President Joe Biden is is leading but
this is this is the effort of the United
States part to really develop large
research cohorts and the precision
medicine initiative has issued its first
round of funding announcements to fund
cohorts that would contribute or groups
that would contribute to these this
cohort and I just want to point out that
that I'm talking about the United States
but there are many other national bio
banks at the international level and
here just a couple of examples
I'm certainly not being exhaustive and
there are a lot of groups and countries
that are trying to develop these large
research cohorts to help with genomic
interpretation so there are several
different models that have developed
with regard to data repositories over
the last several years and this is a
slide that is adapted from Heidi Rehm
that really search shows kind of three
key models one is the centralized
database that I think was originally
envisioned by the National Academies of
Sciences and its report in 2011 where
everyone submits data to a single
centralized database and we see some
initiatives that are using the
centralized database model the second
model here is the centralized hub where
you have each database is sort of
connected to a centralized hub and you
might go through the hub to access the
data but then it's outsourced to the
individual sites or locations to to
control the data locally and then we
have the federated model where all
databases are connected through multiple
sort of arrangements and agreements and
you can see here that there's a lot of
different research initiatives that are
using these various models and adapting
them but I think ultimately what we're
going to have to accomplish is not just
one research repository but a networked
environment of various different data
repositories and I think in an ideal
world this would be an internationally
networked environment we obviously have
to deal with not just data coming from
multiple sources like technology
companies government programs research
consortia healthcare systems and
clinical labs NGOs etc but also them
coming from different countries that
have different regulatory frameworks and
different jurisdictional issues that
need to be attended to as well as
different cultural norms and values so
one of the major problems that prevents
us from getting there is this this
problem of the non Commons and the
they a slide that was created by my
colleague Bob Deegan who loves the slide
and I think it's a neat representation
and it kind of shows and it depicts sort
of the problem that we've seen and kind
of the poster child for this problem of
the non comments has been the myriad
come group and misses you know the the
groovy company that patented the BRCA
gene mutation this was the source of a
huge united states supreme court case in
the past year and in that Supreme Court
case it was determined that myriad could
not hold a patent a valid patent on the
gene mutation for BRCA but we quickly
realized that actually the value that
Mary had had was not only the patent on
the gene but it was in fact a variant
database that it held as a proprietary
trade secret so they had you know done
testing on millions of women over the
last decade and had identified new
variants in the BRCA gene that had been
shown to be associated with breast and
ovarian cancer and those particular
variants were being held as proprietary
trade secrets in their own proprietary
database and were not being shared with
other researchers so if somebody or
other clinicians so if another lab was
doing a BRCA test on an individual
patient and they discovered a variant
they may not have resources or the
database to be able to interpret that
variant based on past cases so this is
the problem of the nod comments and I
just want to tell you a little bit about
some of the research that we've been
doing to address the issue of data
sharing and building a medical
information Commons so the first project
that we had was project called poly seek
and in this project it was kind of a big
project we did a lot of things in it but
one of the things that we did is we had
a we used a Delphi process and we
engaged experts from a variety of
different disciplines and stakeholder
groups and so this slide shows you sort
of the the types of experts experts that
we engaged and these were people that
have really
been thinking about data sharing in a
very high level from LC scholars to
genomic researchers to funders patient
advocates clinical translational
researchers regulators and policymakers
payers and then and then a group of
other individuals we had 43 individuals
in an adelphi process what you do is
you're not trying to get generalizable
sort of opinions but you're trying to
deeply engage these individuals who are
knowledgeable in our experts on the
topic over a series of four engagements
where you're doing in-depth surveys and
we did focus groups with them and we
tried to build on their input to get
deeper deeper into this particular topic
and so in the first two engagements with
them we had them identify and rank what
they thought were the most important
policy challenges that would present a
barrier to the clinical integration of
next generation sequencing and we
focused on the United States because it
was just more manageable although we
recognize that the similar or different
issues might come up internationally and
we identified 19 policy challenges that
they then added to and they ranked in
order of importance and what we found
was the issue of data sharing tied for
the most important policy challenge that
they thought could be the biggest
barrier to the clinical integration of
genomics Ramesh next generation
sequencing but they also ranked data
sharing as the least feasible to address
they thought it would be very very
difficult to address the issue of data
sharing we then ask them for some of
their you know contextual opinions and
perspectives on some of these issues and
we asked them whether companies should
be able to maintain private variant
databases as protected trade secrets as
Miriam is doing with the BRCA variant
database and you can see here that the
vast majority of them either strongly
disagreed or disagreed that companies
should be able to maintain these private
variant databases so you know I think
it's really important to think about
data sharing and and I think it's now
starting to be viewed as a real moral
imperative that individual share their
data this is a paper from
journal of medicine that came out a
couple months ago and it really kind of
got you know a huge negative reaction
because it was about data sharing and it
talked about the concern that secondary
researchers might be considered sort of
research parasites who are getting we're
using data that they didn't collect and
kind of getting all the credits dealing
the fame and the there's sort of a
cartoon about this it says hi guys I'm
sucky to research parasite I'm going to
steal all your data take all the credit
and that was you know that was sort of
like scientists and others came out and
said how could you say that and this is
really setting us back a lot in research
and so the Jeff Drazen who is with one
of the authors and one of the editors of
New England Journal of Medicine wrote a
clarification a couple days later and
says you know new england journal of
medicine believes that there's a moral
obligation to the people who volunteer
to participate in clinical trials to
ensure that their data are widely and
responsibly used so this is recognition
that we really do have a moral
imperative to share data and this this
sort of imperative to share data is
really deeply grounded in the culture of
genomics and a genomics community and
this dates back to the early days of the
human genome project where we had the
Bermuda principles that got developed
that basically called for the rapid
public release of all generated sequence
data very quickly and the rationale
behind that was that this is a public
resource and individual labs is very
expensive to generate sequence data
individual labs across the globe we're
generating parts of the sequence data
and if we could get that out there into
the public domain as quickly as possible
it would speed the science it would
benefit researchers and it would prevent
sort of the privatization of the genome
so the Bermuda principles have really
sort of formed a framework or foundation
for how we think about data sharing in
the genomics world but this slide really
just shows that we're not in Bermuda
anymore things have gotten a lot more
complicated and I don't want to
underestimate how complicated it was and
how difficult it was at the time to come
to an agreement and develop the Bermuda
because it was really challenging the
ways in which science was typically done
and it was really sort of paradigm
shifting in terms of of the culture and
the values of making data broadly
available and who gets credit and those
sorts of things but if it was hard back
in 1996 when we when we had the Bermuda
principles written it's exponentially
more difficult today and I'm going to
give you a couple of reasons of why I
think it's become so much more difficult
the first is that back when we had we
may wrote the Bermuda principles there
were five countries involved in the
human genome project China was added in
1999 but you could basically get 50
people in a room and they were sort of
all the most of the people that were
going to be impacted by the policy that
was developed so they could all give
their input and be part of the process
today we have global programs with many
cultural differences there's you know
thousands of em thousands of individuals
who are working in the space and they
all are dealing with different cultural
differences jurisdictional differences
institutional differences and so it's
very very difficult to get complete
buy-in and consensus on how to move
forward and this is just a an indication
of some of the guidelines and policies
that have been developed by various
groups internationally just to show you
the extent of diversity of groups and
individuals that are thinking about data
sharing norms the second issue has to do
with privacy and identifiability so back
in 1996 that was assumed that if we
publicly released sequence data that
wasn't linked to patient identifying
information than it was de-identified
and privacy was being protected but we
now know that you can no longer do you
identify completely DNA data and one of
the first papers that came out about
this in 2004 really showed that you
could use genomic information you can
identify individuals if you had a
reference sample and if you linked it to
a particular database that had sequence
data in
and all you had to have access to is
about 30 to 80 s statistically
independent snip positions to identify
that the individual that you had a
reference sample for was in that
database so this raised a lot of
questions about are we adequately
protecting privacy of individuals who
contribute their genomic information to
these types of databases we have paper
on this that talked about the fact that
you can no longer de-identified data and
what does that mean from a policy
perspective and then a couple years
later we had papers starting to come out
showing that not only could you identify
individuals from individual level
genomic data but also from aggregate
genomic data and then this culminated
really in a paper that came out in 2013
by a group from MIT that found that you
can actually identify individuals who
are in large research genomic databases
without a reference sample and so this
was a group that looked at they it
matched y-str data from the thousand
genomes database project project
database to genetic genealogy databases
and was able to actually identify about
50 individuals doing a Google search
over a couple hours and so a lot of
people have had sort of looked at these
studies and said well what's the big
deal it's not that easy to do this and
what's the real risk and why are we
worrying so much about privacy and
others have looked at this and said well
this is this is really compelling and we
need to protect individuals and so we
need to strengthen our privacy
protections and our security and and how
we're dealing with the sharing of
genomic data so whatever side you fall
on I think there's no denying that this
actually just complicates the issue a
lot more than what we knew in 1996 the
next two issues have to do with the
diversity of the data so back in 1996
with the Bermuda principles we're really
dealing primarily with human sequence
data and now I think there's a
recognition that we need layers of
genomic data as well as metabolomic
proteomics imaging environmental data as
we want to link it we don't only want
diversity of data we want to link it to
individuals and this idea that if you
have completely sort of anonymous if you
can you know you know we know you can't
anonymize DNA data but anonymize DNA
data
is really no longer that useful to us we
need to know who it came from we need to
have longitudinal data and we need to
have context and so that's a much more
complicated thing to try to manage so
again I bring us back to this idea of
building a medical information Commons
and this idea of having layers of data
that's linked to individuals was very
clearly set out by the National
Academies of science in 2011 in their
report so finally I think there's a
diversity of commercial interests that
didn't exist back in 1996 where the one
goal of the human genome project was to
sequence the human genome that was sort
of the overriding role and everybody was
on board that that's what they wanted to
accomplish now we have many many kinds
of companies with disparate business
models and very different motivations
for why they're in this space and so
this is a paper I'll just reference that
we published in 2014 in the journal
Nature Biotechnology and we looked at a
bunch of companies that were involved in
next-generation sequencing and we sort
of mapped what area along the sequencing
pipeline were they involved in it you
can see from the from the graphic here
these represent individual companies and
what they're doing all the way from you
know developing and selling consumables
and arrays just you know producing
sequencing instruments and supplying
those conducting the sequencing aligning
and annotate and annotating the
sequences that were being done
interpretation and reporting and data
storage and bundling and this is again
not an exhaustive list that these are
the kinds of things that these various
companies are engaged in and what
they're actually doing is going to
impact what their motivation is whether
they have access to data or whether they
can share data and what what impacts
sort of different legal regulatory
issues have on them as a company so I
think where we're at now is really
trying to figure out as a community how
do we incentivize data sharing and I
feel really strongly that although we
may agree that as a scientific community
it is a moral imperative
if we're going to offer whole genome and
whole exome sequencing to patients in a
clinical context that we have robust
enough databases to be able to give them
answers to what we find and so there may
be a moral imperative to share data
broadly speaking and we can we can argue
about that but let's let's just assume
that but even if it is a moral
imperative I don't think that's enough
it can't just be a moral imperative so
many people have pointed out that we
need a business imperative for change
and innovation based on the needs of our
customers and that the barriers to
sharing a really a lack of enabling
infrastructure data governance uniform
policies appropriately constrained
standards and economic incentives so we
need to be thinking about this not just
from an ethical moral perspective but
also from a business perspective so this
leads me back to our policy Delphi that
we did and rounds three and four of that
of that project we took sort of the
top-ranking policy challenges and then
we asked them what should we do about
this and so with regard to data sharing
we asked them what are potential
solutions for dealing with this issue of
data sharing and Indian companies having
proprietary databases and not sharing
data and so this is a little bit of a
difficult graph to read but you can see
here in the blue line shows sort of what
there was support for so you can see
here that down here um there was support
really the highest level of support was
for making data sharing and the
possibility of independent verification
a condition of approval or clearance
certification or accreditation so using
sort of our existing mechanisms like the
FDA or the CMS or cap accreditation to
basically say you have to share data and
making it a condition another another
option that there was some support for
was using positive economic incentives
so that payers reimburse more for tests
from laboratories that share data and
the one the one that received the less
the least amount of support was this
option of doing nothing and that you
know the idea that you can't compel data
disclosure in this space and people were
really opposed to that concept that we
do nothing and just let this happen so
now what we're doing in our group to
build on that project is we have another
grant that's called building the medical
information Commons and it's looking at
participant engagement and policy and we
have a fantastic Advisory Committee and
group of investigators & Co
investigators that are really trying to
grapple with this issue of how can we
create a medical information comments
and we had a really exciting first
meeting back in March where we got at
all of these individuals who have
tremendous expertise in this area and
have been thinking about this area from
their own perspectives of being you know
somebody who works in a clinical lab or
somebody who's running a governmental
program or somebody who's in academia or
we had also people who were in the tech
industry who were doing this from from
that perspective and having them all sit
in a room together and be able to say
okay well this is what's important to us
but this is what's important to you guys
and can how can we work together to try
to think through the businesses
incentives as well as the ethical
imperative to share data and create this
medical information comments and so the
goal of our project is to engage expert
stakeholders to inform polities policy
decisions about effective governance for
data sharing while using deliberative
methods to obtain informed public input
to make sure that the values rights and
interests of individuals whose data
populate the information Commons are
represented so we're doing that in three
stages we're currently working on a
landscape analysis really trying to get
a handle on what are the different
initiatives that are out there in these
different spaces and how are they
sharing data what models are they using
and what are they currently doing and
then we're going to be interviewing
experts stakeholders including members
of our advisory panel but as well as as
other individuals to try to get a sense
of how well identified models of what's
currently going on address key policy
issues and to explore innovative ideas
for addressing unresolved issues and
then finally we're going to take sort of
a couple of different models that are
that are being developed in terms of how
we create this medical information
Commons to members of the public through
citizens panels and this is really an
in-depth way of exploring the values and
soliciting public in
about these key policy issues and the
ways to address innovative innovative
problems and so we'll be doing citizens
panels across the United States to try
to get this really really in-depth
informed public input on some of these
issues so we're really really excited
about this project this is some very
preliminary data based on the first 22
initiatives that we've done extensive
data collection on and this is from a
publicly available data on the internet
but you can see the kinds of data that
are being banked it's not just genetic
data anymore it's not just sequence data
anymore its data its proteins and
phenotypes images demographics other
kinds of information so this gets back
to the issue of linking data and you can
see the kind of data sharing models that
are being adopted so of the 22 that we
initially looked at about thirty two
percent of them have the centralized
model 60 point four percent used a
centralized hub and about five percent
are currently using a federated model
and there may be other models out there
that we need to explore as well that
that offer alternative types of
structures so I just want to kind of I'm
getting close to ending but I want to
point out what participants perspectives
are on this and what we know about that
from our own work so this is from a
study that was done actually several
years ago but we asked individuals who
are being recruited into genomic studies
and these were primarily patients who
were sick themselves or parents of
pediatric patients who had sick kids and
they were asked to never being asked to
participate in genomic studies have
their biological specimens stored and
used for genomic analysis and then to
have their data shared and we did a
randomized trial of different types of
consents that gave varying amounts of
control over the decision to share their
data and the the different options we
gave them is whether their data can be
shared in publicly accessible databases
or open access databases versus shared
in these controlled access databases
where you have to go through like a data
access committee to get the data or not
sure at all and then at the end of the
study we sort of told everybody we
debrief them and said here's what we did
here are all the options for you and how
would you like to have your data shared
so at the end of the study when we gave
everybody
all of the options the majority of our
participants agreed to share their data
either publicly which was fifty-three
percent of them or in controlled access
databases which was thirty-three percent
of them now their motivation for sharing
their data was really altruistic they
wanted to advance research and I have to
do a caveat here which is that you know
our participants although he has I think
335 participants it wasn't a small
number but these were all individuals
who were sick and they were highly
motivated to participate in research
they were all in a large academic
medical setting there was a high high
high level of trust in the institution
as well as in the physician that was
seeking their informed consent and so
this might not scale to other
populations and we need to be very
sensitive to variation in how people
feel about this and so for example we
had a much smaller pilot study that we
did with very disadvantaged poor
primarily african-american participants
who were HIV positive and we asked them
how they felt about sharing their data
and we had kind of a very very inverse
finding which was that most of them were
concerned about sharing their data and
they cared a lot more about their
privacy and that outweighed their desire
to advance research so we do need to be
sensitive to that there might be other
populations as well or individuals who
have particular feelings about this that
don't conform to the majority but for
our participants also we asked them how
important what it was to them to be
involved in the decision about sharing
their data and eighty-six percent felt
that it was very important for them to
be involved and we asked how they wanted
to be involved in most of them just
wanted to be asked and it wasn't because
they were terribly concerned about their
privacy it was really about feeling
respected as a participant in the
research and so they felt like that was
a really important aspect of respect for
persons so in our in our new study that
we're doing on building a medical
information Commons we're going to try
to take the this sort of survey
interview data that we have from actual
research participants and try to explore
the values of the public under
buying data sharing and so we're going
to do this public deliberation and we're
going to look at public views on several
of the ethical issues that come up as
well as try to get at the value tensions
that are at stake when we talk about
sharing data and building a medical
information commons and i just want to
end by pointing out that i think one of
the major big elephants in the room when
we talk about data sharing when we talk
about data repositories and medical
information commons is this question of
who owns your genetic data and this is a
photo I don't know how many of you can
see this well but it's a it's a
photograph I found on the Internet of an
elephant on President Obama's back and
the reason I include this picture of
President Obama is because a couple
months ago he held a conference in the
white house around the precision
medicine initiative and in the
conference he was sort of coded as
saying I would like to think that if
somebody does a test on me or my genes
that that's mine but that's not always
how we define these issues so this
really brings up the question of who
owns your genetic data and what do we
mean by ownership I think what lawyers
mean by ownership might be very very
different than what patients and
participants think of when they say it's
my data or I own the data and what
rights and obligations do those various
meanings give rise to and I think that's
one of the critical issues that we need
to address as we start moving towards
building a medical information comments
so i will end there and open it up to
questions and discussion and i really
appreciate your attention and your time
well thank you dr. McGuire for that
really informative presentation I think
the audience and I really enjoyed it I
think it's time for now for the question
and answer session if you have a
question you'd like to ask dr. McGuire
please do so now just click on the green
Q&A button that's located at the lower
left of the presentation window type in
your question in the box that appears on
the screen and click on the send button
will answer as many questions as we can
today so let's get started the first
question we have for dr. McGuire is from
Allah potty um and this question is
pertaining to the case the case study
that you brought up about
and he asks how do men get how do you
get men to participate in caring about
health care results and as a second
question he asks what can be used for
non symptomatic or asymptomatic health
issues such as in cases like Hannah's
okay okay thank you for that for those
questions so I hope I answer them I'm
not sure I fully understand the question
so if you want to ask the follow-up I'm
not actually getting what you're asking
me feel free to but how do we get men to
care about health care results so you
know in this particular case of Hannah
this was a finding on mitochondrial
sequencing so this was an you know a
female linked particular result but for
for many findings you know they're
equally relevant to men as they are two
women so I think they care about it with
regard to newborn sequencing you know I
do think that a lot of men care care a
lot about it in our baby seek study
we're one of the few studies that are
actually trying to survey the male
partners when we're surveying parents of
these children who are being sequenced
and a lot of the studies that we have
particularly around parental views or
perspectives really focus on the mom
because the mom is typically the one who
fills out the surveys and answers the
question so we're going to great lengths
to try to get both mom and dad where
there is a mom and dad to complete the
survey so that we have a better
understanding of how dads and men feel
about these issues as they relate to
their newborn children um the question
about what do you what do you do with
symptomatic health issues um I'm not one
hundred percent sure I understand that
question but you know I think when we
have individuals we really use genomic
sequencing in a couple different context
one is that you have an individual who
has a particular phenotype they're sick
and you're trying to get a diagnosis
you're trying to understand what's going
on with them and in some cases in very
few cases actually but you're trying to
sometimes we can actually figure out not
just what's going on with them but is
there something
can do to help improve their their
prognosis or their health care in other
cases you may have somebody like Hannah
who is currently asymptomatic but you
find that they have a genetic variant
that shows that they're an increased
risk for a particular disease or
disorder and for some of those they're
actionable so there might be things and
this is sort of the the public health
justification for what's included on
newborn screening panels is that you're
supposed to only be screening for things
that not only occur in childhood but
that are actionable so you can do
something to either prevent or treat the
disease early on but for some things we
don't know if they're actionable we
don't know what to do about them so for
this particular case there was nothing
clearly actionable that could be done
other than increased surveillance and
screening for early signs of the disease
so I hope that answered your question
your question it was an interesting
question is those are great answers
thank you next we have a question from
Korean who asked how can the rapid
evolution of genomic affect genetic
counseling so that is a fantastic
question I think one of the major
challenges that we have right now is
that we do not have enough genetic
counselors and even the genetic
counselors that we do have not all of
them have been trained and how to do
sort of what we call genomic counseling
right so they may be very comfortable
and familiar with how to counsel
families about single gene tests that
are being done but may not be as
familiar or comfortable with how to
counsel around genomic findings and so I
think a lot of the like we have a new
genetic counseling master's program
that's starting at Baylor College of
Medicine and I think that will focus a
lot on sort of genomic counseling and
training people and being comfortable
with genome-wide results and how to
interpret that in how to counsel
families and individuals on the basis of
those results but there's a slide that I
don't have in my slide deck but I
seen before that shows the number of new
postings for genetic counseling jobs
that are out there and and it's up here
and the number of genetic counselors
that are coming out of training programs
and it's like down here right so there's
a huge gap between the perceived need
for genetic counselors and the number of
genetic counselors that we have at our
disposal for for the field and so you
know this raises a couple of issues one
is are we going to increase the number
of genetic counselors and train more
people and I think we're trying to do
that and if this really scales based on
that first that first slide that I
showed with regard to how quickly we're
integrating genomic so I'm going to try
to pull it back up here if this really
scales at this level of being you know
we're doing a million now worldwide and
you know based on any of these we're
going to be doing a billion genomic
sequences eventually right if that
really scales at that level I think
we're going to have to come to grips
with the fact that all clinicians are
going to have to feel more comfortable
than they do now with helping to
interpret genomic sequencing findings
and helping to counsel patients and
their families and then really referring
for the most complicated cases so in the
med seek study we're actually studying
that the results are being given back by
primary care physicians and
cardiologists and they're receiving some
minimal training from our study team and
then kind of were auto-drivers with
their patients to really look at how do
they do when they're given a genome
report and they have to educate and
counsel their patients on what it means
for them and they're doing pretty well
actually there's there's they're not
they're not having a lot of examples of
misinformation or anything wrong and
we're watching for that okay XO
next we have a question from Tammy who
asked what what models allow patients to
have access to their medical records and
business impact the patient's
perspective on sharing of medical data
so that's another great question and
it's one that I think we're really
struggling with so the we had this
meeting I mentioned in March with a lot
of experts on who are dealing with data
sharing from a lot of different
perspectives and one of the key themes
that came up from that meeting was that
we really need to be participants
centric in how we do this and so it's
it's it's not going to work to ask
individuals to share their data and not
give them access to their own
information and so we need to do a much
better job at not only creating the
regulatory structure in all the
different countries for people to be
able to access their medical record and
their their genomic data and everything
else but to actually make it possible
for them to do that so you know we do
have laws in place that say you can
access your medical record we actually
have laws now in the United States and
say you can access your raw data and
your lab reports but most people find
that very difficult to accomplish and to
do and you know there's kind of a whole
bunch of bureaucracy they have to go to
in order to get access to the
information that they want so i think
that's that's an area that we really
need to work on and i do think it's sort
of a principle of reciprocity that if
we're going to ask people to contribute
to the medical information commons they
need to be able to get back at least
their own information from that same
comments
okay great um finally we have a question
from Sylvia and her question pertains to
ethics and data sharing from diseases or
from born vectors such as mosquitoes
which I don't know if you can comment on
that for us yeah so I'm not sure I'm the
right person to comment on that I'm
really sorry I'm not sure exactly what
the question is I think you know they're
there is a huge need to be thinking
about infectious diseases you know with
the Zika virus and and the other
infectious diseases that we're seeing
through mosquitoes and other pathogens
and thinking about how can we share data
related to that it's not an area that
I've done a tremendous amount of work in
but I think it's a really really
important area to be thinking about and
how do we link that with all of the
other medical information about
individuals is is going to be incredibly
important okay um next we have a
question from Kathleen and the question
is a little bit long so feel free to
read along with me Amy she asks a unique
RFID type extremely confidential label
be assigned to any data originating from
each individual patient and then she
says this could then be used to identify
any breach of confidentiality in the use
or accessibility of their data and
allowed for the individual patient to
monitor their data use ok yeah so much
I'm trying to look at this again I'm not
sure if I'm the best person to answer
this but I do think that there's ways to
identify breaches and confidentiality
and there are certain groups I would I
think the group out of Vanderbilt is
probably to my knowledge from those
forward thinking on this and how they're
tracking
access to data and looking at sort of
legitimate use and identifying breaches
in data access and they have a very
sophisticated sort of informatics way of
doing this that it's a one-way
filtration system I don't fully
understand it Brian Malin is kind of the
expert on this and for those who are
interested in this topic I'd recommend
that you reach out to him but I do think
there's ways to do this and I think the
issue that you bring up with regard to
focusing not on the front end which is
data access right so restricting who can
access the data putting it behind many
many firewalls etc but rather focusing
more on the back end of who is in an
unauthorized fashion accessing data
who's using data in harmful ways or
against you know data use agreements and
really having sort of strong punishments
or consequences for that type of misuse
I think that's where we need to be
focusing a little bit more as i
mentioned in europe the human tissue act
really sort of criminalizes the analysis
of DNA without consent that's one
approach on you know we can argue about
whether that's the right approach but at
least it focuses on sort of what are
people doing with the data if they have
access to it and not so much sort of how
are we storing the data and who's
contributing it and those sorts of
things I think you need to address it
from both sides but in the United States
at least I think we have been overly
focused on the front end and don't have
as as as strong protections for the back
end misuse
okay guess we have a question from Diane
and who says the issue of genetic
ownership varies across culture within
the United States some Native Americans
feel their genetic data reflects
extended kinship networks hence
ownership is a non-issue does your
research seek to address issues like
these or would citizen panels of a cross
cultural representation yeah so thank
you for that question that's another
excellent question I'm absolutely true
different people different cultures feel
very differently about issues of
ownership so our study and you know I'm
glad you brought up Native Americans
because I think that's a population in
the United States where we have really
sort of had an interesting relationship
with those with those groups with regard
to genetic research and the recent
havasu paid tribe case of Arizona where
there was a lot of controversy about the
use of genetic samples from the Hobby
soup a tribe really sort of highlighted
some of the cultural differences and and
and how we think about this and some of
the dangers of not paying attention to
that and being respectful of that so our
particular study is is focused on is not
focused on that we will ask those which
we try to get broad representation from
different you know demographic
backgrounds and our citizen panels and
we will ask about values around
ownership and so hopefully some of those
issues will come up but we are working
very closely with two individuals to
scholars who are those Native American
their Native Americans their
representatives of the Native American
communities and they're also scholars in
ethical legal and social implications of
genetics and genomics so Jesse bar dill
and on non of a garrison they're both
consultants on our project and we're
working with them to try to figure out
can we do some parallel research with
the Native American community to try to
see how we can sort of be respectful of
and be attentive to the particular
particular cultural values that exist in
those communities and
you know I don't want to say that all
Native American tribes have the same
culture around this either I think there
are a lot of differences in various
communities and we need to be very
sensitive to that okay if they're more
if there are no more questions I would
like to thank those of you who ask such
excellent and engaging questions and of
course I would like to thank dr. McGuire
again for excellent presentation do you
have any final comments for us before we
leave I just want to thank everybody for
joining us this has been really great
and it's been wonderful to engage with
you the last couple of minutes and soon
thank you very much for moderating and
for inviting me to be part of this
conference who is wonderful and we'd
love to have you again so before we go I
want to let everyone know that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing until November 2016 you receive
an email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast is available for
replay and we encourage you to share
that link with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event that's
all we have for now I would thank you
for joining I would hope to see you
again next time bye